>> MARCO: Hi, I'm Marco. I'm a multimedia
software engineer on the Android project and
I’d like to show you my favorite feature
of the music player. So, here I am listening
to some music in the music player and one
of the things I can do is click on the artist
name and a little pop-up comes up, I select
Amazon MP3 and I was searching the Amazon
MP3 store for albums by this artist. And here’s
the whole list of things that I can buy. Another
thing I can do is long press on the song name
and again, I’ll do an Amazon MP3 search
and it only finds one album but if I go over
the songs, you can see a whole list of songs,
remixes, karaoke mixes, tribute, groups, et
cetera. Another thing I can do is search for
Radiohead on Google, and from there, I can
go to the official Radiohead website, read
their Wikipedia entry, see their Myspace page,
et cetera. So, let’s pick a more recent
song. Now, I happen to know that this song
has a really cool video. So, I long press
on the title and I do a YouTube search.
And here it is, the first one and the music
stops playing. It’s loading the video and
now I'm watching the music video of the song
that I was just listening to.